- Britney Spears is actively
challenging the conservatorship
that has dominated every
aspect of her life since 2008.
But why?
Well, reportedly the conservator,
that is the guy in charge of her life
was making $10,000 a week
while she was only given
an allowance of $2,000.
She was forced to get an IUD
so that she couldn't have another child
and she was appointed a
lawyer who never told her
that she could challenge
the conservatorship.
And that is just the tip of the iceberg.
- [Britney] I shouldn't
be in a conservatorship
if I can work and provide
money and work for myself
and pay other people.
- Britney testified in a probate
hearing for the first time
in over a decade and she tells
a story about being forced
to perform against her will.
- [Britney] He handed me a sheet of paper
as I got off the stage in Vegas
and said I had to sign it.
It was very threatening and scary
and with the conservatorship,
I couldn't even get my own attorney.
So out of fear, I went
ahead and I did the tour.
- And despite the conservatorship
during the preparations for this tour,
she took responsibility for rehearsing
and directing her own dancers.
- [Britney] I wasn't good, I was great.
I let a room of 16 new
dancers in rehearsals.
It's funny to hear my
managers' side of the story.
They all said I wasn't
participating in rehearsals
and I never agreed to take my medication.
Ma'am, I'm not here to be anyone's slave.
I can say no to a dance move.
- She also said her conservatorship
which has mostly been directed
by her father, Jamie Spears
refuses to allow her to
marry and have children.
- [Britney] I wanna be able to
get married and have a baby.
I was told right now
in the conservatorship
I'm not able to get
married or have a baby.
I have an IUD and side of myself right now
so I don't get pregnant.
I wanted to take the IUD
out so I could start trying
to have another baby but the
so-called team won't let me go
to the doctor to take it out
because they don't want
me to have children.
- The things Britney said
about her conservatorship
are harrowing and include
allegations of abuse.
And there are of course circumstances
when a court-appointed
conservator is given the right
to assume responsibility for
someone else's life decisions,
and that makes sense.
Although Britney's conservatorship
was originally based on her
own mental health crisis,
one would assume it takes
more than that to maintain
the legal conservatorship
for more than a decade
over a seemingly functional adult.
But we don't have to look
very hard to find people
who have repeatedly filed for bankruptcy
or have had very public
mental health crises
or have had a serious drug habit
and cause their life to
spiral out of control.
And even those who are being manipulated
and conned out of their money.
But none of these people
have been subjected
to a conservatorship
the kind that Britney
Spears has been under
for a decade.
So, what does it take for
a court to put a person
under a general conservatorship?
And why does Britney Spears want
to end this conservatorship in a case?
Well, today I'm going
to tell you everything
you need to know about what is
happening to Britney Spears.
(gentle music)
Hey Legal Eagles, it's time to think
like a guardian ad litem
because Britney Spears has
been under a conservatorship
for over a decade.
So, what is a conservatorship?
Well, a conservatorship is a
court appointed arrangement
in which person or organization has chosen
to protect and manage their finances
and at times the personal care of someone
whom a judge has found
to be unable to manage
their own affairs.
A conservator is responsible
for using their judgment
to arrange for the care and protection
of the person under the conservatorship.
The person under the conservatorship
is known as the conservatee.
Now, there are a few different
kinds of conservatorships
under California law.
Britney Spears has been under
a general conservatorship
since 2008.
This is governed by the
California probate court.
There are conservatorships of adults
who cannot handle their
finances, personal care, or both.
This consists of two parts.
Conservatorships of the estate
and conservatorships of a person.
A conservator of the estate is appointed
to administer the person's financial life
such as investing the person's money,
protecting their assets,
paying their bills
and budgeting for expenses.
A conservator of the person takes charge
of the person's nonfinancial life.
Now, the specifics differ
depending on each person's circumstances
but generally conservator can decide
where the person will live,
whether they receive an allowance
and whether they can make
their own personal care
and health decisions.
General conservatorships
have no termination date.
They can and usually do last
until the end of the person's life.
But at the same time,
the vast majority of
these conservatorships
involve the elderly or the infirm people
that manifestly cannot
take care of themselves.
So, it's not something
that lasts 50 years,
it might be something
that lasts five years
until they pass away.
But let's talk about the
scope of conservatorships
because once a conservatorship
is established,
the limitations on a conservatives freedom
are incredibly broad.
As disability rights
lawyer, Patricia Cavey
points out quote,
"In many ways, the deprivation of Liberty
through an involuntary guardianship order
is greater than that
suffered by convicted felon.
Prisoners retain basic rights
to control medical decisions,
bodily integrity and the right to conduct
their business affairs
and retain their estate.
Wards do not."
The due process protections
of the 14th amendment
apply to guardianships
and conservatorships
but due process only
guarantees the right to notice
in a court hearing.
The Supreme court has never decided a case
establishing the precise
parameters of due process
in the context of guardianships
or conservatorship.
This means that there is
no universal requirement
that people who are subject
to conservatorship proceedings
have specific rights
like a sixth amendment
right to an attorney.
Most states require or allow
the appointment of a lawyer
but they don't necessarily
let the conservative choose
their own lawyer.
Once a conservatorship is established,
the cost of administering
the person's life
are paid by the conservatee,
the person who is under the
care of these other people.
This doesn't automatically mean
that there's a conflict of interest
but it's something that Britney flagged
when she spoke in court.
The fact that her family
lives off of her fortune
and her performances provide
a living for many people
creates a conflict of interest.
- [Britney] It's been a long
time since I've owned my money
and it's my wish and my
dream for all of this to end,
without being tested.
Again, it makes no sense
whatsoever for the state
of California to sit back
and literally watched me
with their own two eyes,
make a living for so many
people and pay so many people.
Trucks and buses on tour
on the road with me,
and be told I'm not good enough
but I'm great at what I do.
- So, that brings us to
the very obvious question
of who is able to
initiate a conservatorship
over another adult?
Well, any person who
wants to be a conservator
can file a petition for conservatorship.
This could be a spouse,
a relative, a friend
or even a manager.
And under the law, the
court gives preference
to certain people, a
spouse, adult, children,
parents, sibling or another person.
And in Spear's case,
her father, Jamie Spears
filed a petition for temporary
conservatorship in 2008.
This was later converted to
a general conservatorship
and he sought and received
the right to manage the estate
and her person.
Attorney Andrew Wallet was
later named co-conservator.
And now, why was
Britney's father appointed
as a conservator?
Well, because she was
not married at the time,
there was no one else
higher on the priority list
and it's possible for the same person
to become a conservator of
both the state and the person.
To be appointed as both,
separate petitions have to be filed.
So, what is the legal standard
to force another adult person
into a conservatorship?
Well, California Probate Code section 1821
requires the initial petition
to show the following.
Number one, the inability
of the proposed conservatee
to properly provide for his or her needs
for physical health, food,
clothing, and shelter.
Two, the location of the proposed
conservativee's residence
and the ability of the
proposed conservatee
to live in the residence
while under conservatorship.
Three, alternatives to conservatorship
considered by the petitioner
or proposed conservator
and reasons why those
alternatives are not available.
Number four, health and social services
provided to the proposed conservatee
during the year proceeding
the filing of the petition
and number five, the inability
of the proposed conservatee
to substantially manage his
or her own financial resources
or to resist fraud or undue influence.
This is, and frankly
should be a very high bar
for the petitioner to clear.
The facts need to show
that the person is not capable
of taking care of themselves
or of managing their own finances
or that they are
susceptible to manipulation.
Now, in the case of Britney Spears,
we don't know exactly
what the facts were that the court relied
on when it determined that
Britney needed a conservatorship
back in 2008.
When Jamie Spears petitioned
the probate court,
Britney had been through enormous upheaval
in a very short period of time.
Britney was harassed
repeatedly by the paparazzi.
She publicly shaved her
head shortly after the death
of her beloved aunt and this
event was captured by cameras
and became an enormous tabloid story.
She was also in a divorce
and in a custody battle
with Kevin Federline,
she had voluntarily gone to rehab
and done two stints in a
psychiatric institution.
We assume that she has a disability
but we don't know whether she
has any psychiatric diagnosis.
Now, Jamie Spears also told the court
that Britney's new manager,
Sam Lutfi was abusing her
and the court in these proceedings
entered a restraining order against Lutfi.
Now, while we don't have
all of this information,
I don't think anyone seriously
questioned the necessity
of the Spears conservatorship at the time.
However, in retrospect,
it's fair to ask whether the Spears family
could have used a less restrictive measure
to protect Britney or
whether this conservatorship
has gone on for way too long.
Now, what are some less
restrictive measures
that could have been instituted?
Well, for starters, the power of attorney
where a person legally
authorizes an individual
to make financial decisions for them.
This could be a spouse, a friend,
a manager, or even lawyer.
A person might also agree
to give temporary custody
to their children to their ex.
Giving someone power of attorney
allows them to make
decisions on your behalf
but it doesn't allow them to control
your every waking moment.
There can be mediations
in court ordered rehab
when drugs are an issue.
And someone who has power of
attorney can create a trust
and pay the bills of their client
and put them on an allowance.
All of these are serious steps,
they don't compare to the
severity of a conservatorship
but of course, sometimes
conservatorship is necessary.
Now, you might ask, "Aren't
there some legal safeguards
to make sure that the
conservatorship is necessary
on a continual basis?"
Well, there are supposed to be safe guards
in these arranges.
The conservator has to
periodically report to the court
about the status of the situation.
In some circumstances,
the conservator will need court's approval
to make certain decisions.
And in the beginning of this process,
a court appointed investigator is response
for interviewing the
potential conservatee,
explaining their rights
and making recommendations to the judge.
However, after the
conservatorship is established,
the investigator only
speaks to the conservatee
every two years.
And here, Jamie Spears
maintained full control
over Britney even after
there Sam Lutfi was gone,
her divorce and custody
arrangements were final
and her drug use had apparently ended.
Public reports show that Jamie, quote.
Had the authority to restrict
and limit her visitors
oversee her personal security
and dictate her medical
and psychiatric treatment.
Jamie has repeatedly said
that he only wants what's
right in her best interest
and that he loves his daughter
and wouldn't force her to do anything
that you wouldn't want to do.
But of course the FreeBritney movement
has pointed out cracks
in this facade for years.
When Britney had a successful
run of shows in Las Vegas,
people started to question
why a highly skilled performer
was still under a conservatorship.
Then things started to
unravel publicly in 2019.
In January, Jamie's
original co-conservator
Andrew Wallet resigned
after asking for a raise.
That left Jamie Spears
as the sole conservator
of both Spears as person and estate.
The New York Times recently
reviewed a transcript
of a hearing from the spring of 2019
when Britney's lawyer "asserted
that she had been forced
into mental health
facilities against her will
on exaggerated grounds which
she viewed as punishment
for standing up for herself
and making an objection
during a rehearsal."
At that time, Britney's
lawyer filed a document
saying that Britney was
afraid of her father.
And later in 2019, Kevin
Federline backed up this claim.
He helped their teen sons
file for a restraining order
against Jamie because of something he did
to one of their children
when they visited with Jamie.
And Federline's attorney said,
"Britney exercised
appropriate parental conduct
removing her children from
a dangerous situation."
This order was granted
without opposition from Jamie
and barred him from contact
with the boys for three years.
In September of 2019, Jamie
spheres asked to be released
from managing Britney's personal care.
The court appointed Jodi Montgomery,
a professional conservator.
Jamie continues in his role
as manager of the estate
and he's told the court
that he opposes ending
his conservatorship.
The court allowed Jamie to
take a 1.5% cut of everything
Britney makes from her performances.
This is in addition to his
monthly salary of $16,000
for acting as conservator
and doesn't include
Jamie's attorney's fees,
which are also paid out
of Britney's estate.
Britney said "They've done a good job
at exploiting my life."
Talking about her father and
Montgomery in June of 2021
when she addressed the
court for the first time.
So, what about the lawyer?
Well, Britney has a
court appointed lawyer,
Samuel D. Ingram III.
Under California probate
code section 1470 and 1471,
judges are required to appoint counsel
for the proposed conservatee
in some situations.
Most court clerks have a
rotating list of lawyers
who serve as court appointed counsel.
Now, in practice, this means
that the person isn't
picking their own lawyer.
Now, how can this be?
Well, the basis for conservatorship
is literally the person isn't competent
to enter into contracts.
So, Jamie Spears has repeatedly
emphasized his belief
that his daughter is not capable
of handling her own business
without being taken
advantage of by other people.
And since this is the very foundation
of the conservatorship,
a judge can also presume
that the person isn't competent
to hire their own lawyer.
And Ingram told the court in 2020
that Britney wanted her father replaced
by Bessemer Trust as co-conservator.
The Bessemer Trust is a bank.
Now, Ingram told the court that
Britney was actually afraid
of her father and that in the future
he might file a petition
to end the conservatorship.
But despite Britney's apparent discomfort
with a conservatorship,
Ingram never filed a petition to end it.
And according to news
reports, Ingram told the court
that Britney wanted a chance to speak
but he had no idea what she would say.
During the court hearing,
Britney said that he never told
her she had a right to file
a petition to end the consevatorship.
- [Britney] I was told I have to sit down
and be evaluated again if I
wanna end the conservatorship.
Ma'am I didn't know I could petition
the conservatorship to end it.
I'm sorry for my ignorance
but I honestly didn't know that.
I don't feel like I
should even be in a room
with anyone to offend me
by trying to question my
capacity of intelligence.
Whether I need to be in this
stupid conservatorship or not.
- If this is true, this could
be a serious ethical lapse
because just because
the lawyer is appointed
doesn't mean that they don't have
all of the same ethical
obligations to any client
to zealously represent that client
to the best of their abilities
and in the best interests of their client.
And there are other holes in the record
regarding Ingram as well.
Probate law allows the court
to set the lawyer's fee
and to bill it to the
conservatives estate.
And Ingram right now is
making $10,000 a week
in fees as her lawyer.
Yet neither he nor the court
could produce the order
which established his rate or allowed him
to build that much.
It's possible that he was making
$10,000 a week since 2008.
All the while there are reports
that Britney was given an
allowance of only $2,000 a week.
All the while, her estate is
worth north of $60 million.
However, at the same time,
Britney says she also has developed
a good relationship with Ingram.
- [Britney] Actually I've grown
with a personal relationship
with my lawyer.
I've been talking to him like
three times in a week now
and we've kind of built a relationship
but I haven't really had the
opportunity by my own self
to actually handpick
my own lawyer by myself
and I would like to be able to do that.
- It's theoretically possible
based on the size of the estate
that these fees are warranted.
It's possible based on the
amount of work that he is doing,
that these fees are warranted
but we just don't happen to know.
The situation with
Ingram just isn't clear,
but it certainly seems
suspicious on its face.
And what we're witnessing
here may be true confusion
by Britney and Ingram
about the lawyer's role.
The nature of the
conservatorship can often blur
the ethical lines between
advocate and guardian.
California law requires lawyers
to maintain confidentiality
and loyalty to their clients
and there's no exception for lawyers
appointed to represent conservatees.
And in fact, California
rejected the proposed rule
of professional conduct
which would have given
lawyers some freedom
to give their own opinion
about their clients
with diminished capacity.
For example, San Diego lawyers
and Rudolf and Ralph Hughes
argued that the nature of
conservatorship encourages lawyers
to actually report on
their clients to the court
explaining what they feel
is in the best interest of their client
rather than advocating for what
their clients actually want.
They say that this violates
lawyer's ethical duty
to keep attorney client
communications confidential.
And in their view, this
violates a lawyer's ethical duty
to zealously advocate for their client.
A lawyer cannot tell the
court what the client has said
without the client's consent,
cannot ignore the client's
stated desires and goals
and count advocate something
that the client does not want.
So for example, this could lead a lawyer
to using the best interest
standard to make decisions
about the client's mental capacity,
decisions that arguably the
lawyer isn't qualified to make.
And in other words, a
court appointed lawyer
should be an advocate for
what the client wants,
not act as a guardian ad litem
who substitutes their own
judgment for the client's wishes.
And it's also important to recognize
that despite the we're
here to help attitude,
conservatorships are
inherently adversarial.
They strip people of their
most fundamental rights.
Now, most lawyers would say
that the nature of this process
requires lawyers to be zealous advocates
but in California, there
are court decisions
allowing lawyers to exercise
their independent judgment
on crucial matters
impacting their conservatee.
Including whether to withdraw life support
in cases permitting lawyers
to decide to pull the plug
and appeals court has emphasized
that there isn't a law requiring
a court to get involved
in a conservator's decision
to literally withdraw life support.
This raises another question.
Does the court get involved
when other fundamental rights
are at stake like reproduction?
Well, we sort of have an example
in the case of Britney Spears,
because choosing whether
and when to children
is a fundamental constitutional right
that includes the right of procreation,
sterilization, and abortion
yet coerced sterilization in the U.S
has a long and horrible legal history.
In 1927, Oliver Wendell Holmes,
one of the most respected
jurists of all time
wrote one of the most shocking
Supreme court opinions
ever in Buck versus Bell
which upheld Virginia's
Eugenics Sterilization Act.
This law allow the state to
forcibly sterilize Carrie Buck,
a poor woman that the state had said
should not be able to have children.
The opinion is infamous
because Holmes wrote
three generations of imbeciles is enough.
Carrie Buck actually didn't
have any discernible disability
but her foster family
initiated a court proceeding
against her after their
nephew sexually assaulted her.
The case is a lesson
on how easy it could be
to convince a court, to take
away a person's freedom.
It's also a lesson in
even respected jurists
on the Supreme court get things
horribly, horribly wrong.
And after Buck versus Bell,
America sterilized about 70,000 people.
And in this case,
Britney told the court...
- [Britney] I wanted to take
the IUD out so I could start
trying to have another baby
but the so-called team won't
let me go to the doctor
to take it out because they
don't want me to have children.
- This means that some
point she got an IUD
that prevents pregnancy
but when she decided that she'd
like to have another child,
her conservatorship, run by her father
refused to allow her to see
a doctor about taking it out.
We don't know whether
there was ever a hearing
regarding Britney's IUD
but the rules of conservatorship
do not expressly require one
even though it obviously
impacts a fundamental right.
Just as no California statute
or decision purports to
require judicial approval
of a conservator's decision
to forego further medical treatment,
there's no statute
requiring judicial approval
of a conservator's decision
to limit a conservatees
reproductive choices.
A conservatorship is broad and powerful
since medical decisions are
part of the conservatorship
of the person.
Britney has no final say over
her own medical treatment
including whether she uses birth control.
And this court has delegated
power to conservatives.
So, it takes a hands off role
unless there is a petition to
terminate the conservatorship.
So, let's talk about whether it's possible
to end a conservatorship and
whether it should be ended.
One of the reasons that
the Spears conservatorship
started to get attention
was because Britney's
activities seem to undermine
Jamie's assertions that she
needed it in the first place.
And let's just look at
what Britney has done
over the last 13 years.
She's released four albums,
served as a judge on a reality show
and performed hundreds of shows
during a Las Vegas residency.
Judging by her work, Britney
is in a very different place
than she was in 2008.
Why is a woman who is not
yet 40 with a full-time
and very demanding job who
shares custody of two children
still under a conservatorship?
Remember this isn't about
being bad with money
or using drugs or refusing to
go to therapy or anything else
that a lot of other
Americans may struggle with.
For the conservatorship to be necessary,
the person must still be
unable to manage their affairs.
The legal standard remains
that a person is unable
to provide basic needs like
food, clothing, shelter,
and be incapable of
making medical decisions.
For financial decisions,
the requirement is a person
being unable to manage
their financial affairs
or resist undue influence.
But here's the problem,
the burden isn't on the conservator
to establish the continuing
need for conservatorship.
The burden is instead on the conservatee
to prove that they don't need it.
And although it may seem pretty
simple to make this showing,
I'm not sure how easy it is.
Now, if you aren't capable
of cooking for yourself
and want to avoid getting
put in a conservatorship,
you've got to try HelloFresh.
Oh God, that's so mean.
Now, I have to say I was
initially pretty skeptical
about HelloFresh.
I'm a pretty good cook,
so I didn't think that I needed the help
but I actually loved it.
Even for an experienced cook,
HelloFresh provides new
ingredients and recipes
that I would never have tried on my own.
Everything I've gotten has
been insanely delicious,
easy to cook and actually really healthy.
And most recently,
I made yogurt marinated
chicken with garlic sauce
and steakhouse
(indistinct)
Both were incredibly delicious
and not something I would
normally make on my own.
If you feel like you've
been cooking the same thing
every day in quarantine,
HelloFresh is great solution.
And of course, everything was
delivered straight to my door,
so I didn't have to do any shopping.
The produce actually gets to you faster
than in a grocery store
so it arrives at peak freshness and flavor
and it's also super easy and saves time.
HelloFresh cuts out meal planning and prep
so the recipes take only
20 to 30 minutes to cook.
Literally less time to cook
than it would normally
take to do the shopping.
And it's also really sustainable
since the ingredients are pre-portioned,
there's less prep and less wasted food.
The packaging is almost
entirely made from recyclable
or already recycled content.
And HelloFresh's carbon
footprint is actually 25% lower
than meals that you would make
from store bought groceries.
So, if you wanna try
HelloFresh, go to hellofresh.com
and use the code LegalEagle14
to get 14 free meals.
Yeah, 14 free meals plus free shipping.
So, again for 14 free
meals, go to hellofresh.com
and use the code LegalEagle14
or click on the link in the description.
Plus, clicking on that link
really helps out this channel.
So, do you agree with my analysis
about the whole Britney situation?
Leave your objections in the comments
and check out this
playlist over here with all
of my other videos about the
legal issues in the news.
So, click on this playlist
or I'll see you in court.